In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at GPU light mass in detail for optimization.
And it's going to be a bit of a review.
So let's go ahead and tackle that.
So GPU light mass, it basically improves on the current light baking system, or I should
say the older light baking system.
It uses a progressive light mapper with optional real time preview in the viewport.
So offering multiple modes for building lighting.
You can do a full bake, or you can bake what you see, which will help speed things up.
It significantly increases the speed of light bakes for complex scenes, producing a more
physically accurate result than CPU based light mass, but it has more limitations.
There's a few things we'll talk about on the back end of this on what those limitations
might be.
So in review, again, we were reviewing this, the other foundational courses talk about
this.
First up, you do need to turn it on to your plugins.
But from there, you also want to make sure your DirectX 12 should be on by default.
But you do need to enable ray tracing.
That needs to be on.
Virtual texturing and virtual texture light maps can show you your interactive preview
as you're working.
If you're working in ICVFX, you don't necessarily need these unless virtual texturing you're
using them.
But for the most part, that update, as you see the bar build things is not really necessary.
The GPU light mask window is now after you do all this accessible to be able to look
at your stuff and to do a quality control pass.
So some of the settings here we're going to briefly talk about.
We're not going to get too much into buttonology.
This is a review, but I'm going to start talking about some of the key features and things
to look out for.
One, again, you have the option to full bake or partially bake.
Make sure you turn off your compressed light maps in your scene.
Here you GI samples and stationary light shadow samples.
You can control that as a sweeping control.
I like to do those on individual level because it's a case by case.
Volumetric light map, a simplified option version of the CPU volumetric light map control.
So you have a little bit of quality control there and iridescence cashing here.
So helps with interior scenes may not be needed to be adjusted.
The default works pretty well.
So workflows here, you have a denoiser here.
No denoising is applied to the lighting render.
And this can be useful for to determine a number of GI samples.
So it's up to you how you edit those.
We can look at the settings in just a bit here.
On completion denoises the results of the light build.
So it makes it a bit cleaner for you.
During the interactive preview, you can also have this here.
It will denoise it on the fly.
You have those options, either none on completion or interactively.
And you can see it do its job.
Now let's go back into Unreal and we'll get back to this slide.
And we're going to take a look at those settings up close.
So in my scene here, you'll see that my build is active and ready to go.
There's a viewport real time is on.
If I wanted to, I could turn that off.
I'm just leaving mine on for now.
There's a full bake or you can just bake what you see.
Again, that option is available for you.
And the denoiser, I have mine the default set on completion.
And again, you can say no or you can have it during the interactive.
So you really do want to try to use that denoiser if you can.
You'll see it says Intel open image denoiser, which works really well.
We have GI samples.
Most of these default work pretty great and it is pretty darn fast and compared to the
CPU build.
So all of these are at your fingertips.
Now let's talk about a few things when it comes to some pro tips and some optimizing.
So final pixel, it's helpful to speed up things and get them ready to go if you need it.
But again, I would lean more towards the lumen or even a path tracer if you're going for
a better visual overall control because there are limitations with reflections and reflective
properties.
They just won't quite look right, especially if they're clear and you can see characters
walking past them.
It's a little bit of a stretch and you'll have to do some tweaking to try to get it.
And there's still high levels of limitations there.
And the fact that the reflections won't look realistic, they'll be screen spaced.
So you might want to switch to path tracer or even ray tracing or lumen in that case
to be able to get the better visuals in that area.
ICVFX, it can be perfect for making quick lighting changes and can be combined with
ray tracing, but you'll have to play with that workflow a bit.
I'll mention it.
But again, I do want to encourage everyone to try to lean towards lumen if you can because
lumen is going to give you the best results, but there may be a shot where you have lots
of noise and you can't get past it.
Then you can actually maybe use this light mass GPU on that case and be able to tweak
things accordingly.
After you do a build, you want to make sure that you go to ray tracing and you turn off
all those effects.
Let's actually look at a build that I just made and run this CVAR and you can see what
I'm talking about.
So once I have this build set up and you see that we've built this, ignore this up here,
it's a little bit of an error.
It's an older conversion from an older version of Unreal, which will continually tell me
it needs to be rebuilt, but it's already done.
So I'm going to go to my output here and I'm going to do control V. And I'm going to go
ahead and get rid of all my ray tracing effects.
And this is going to give me the true bake because remember, GPU light masses using some
of that ray tracing to be able to speed up our process.
Unfortunately, some of that can still be into here and will give us kind of false results.
So I'm going to hit enter.
And when you do that, you now actually make it so that the ray tracing is gone.
Now I may have already run this command in the past and that's fine.
But for the most part, that removes any errors that may be occurring in here and no ray tracing
is going to be set in.
So again, you want to run that CVAR when you can.
Again, that makes it so that that is we're not using any kind of ray tracing.
We're turning it off so that it doesn't interfere with our final results with our scene.
Now again, you can turn them on if you need to, and you can turn them off if you need
to.
You'll see it's turned them on and I will turn it off again just so that you know we are
in the mode we need to.
You can see the shift there.
So that's probably just because I ran that console out in the past.
Cool.
Awesome.
So when running GPU light mass, you may run into a TDR delay situation happening.
If you do, make sure you go into your windows and you want to go to your local machine here
and then you want to set your TDR delay.
You want to modify that and set it to like 60 if you need to.
You can even go a bit higher if you need to.
Never mind here where it says an old reference link.
This is still valid and it's basically just the TDR information that we're using.
And yep.
Here's some limitations and things you need to consider.
So light mass portals are not supported.
We talked about that before.
Real depth offset is still not supported yet.
Lighting channels not supported.
Use light mass importance volumes to help with volumetric light maps.
This is really important to consider because using a light mass importance volume is used
in a regular CPU baking environment and you can find that under volumes but you really
do need it for GPU light mass especially for characters moving around because it actually
helps unreal digest that information for characters moving around for updated shadows.
Now typically in CPU you want to use that because you have priority areas especially
for a larger scene or maybe you're working with terrain but it's really key when it comes
to the GPU light mass.
World position offset is not supported.
Texture encoding and denoising are run on CPU and are not affected by multi GPUs.
You can consider that if you are using the system.
Very skylight currently not supported but on the roadmap and custom settings and properties
of the lights some things such as indirect lighting intensity source texture and a few
other things are not fully supported and quite there yet.
You see a list of limitations found here which can also help you in the direction for 5.3.
Also light channels are not supported so make note of that also.
That's it with this section.
In the next section we're going to go ahead and take a look at screen space global illumination.
Thanks again.